here now is william ruger president of
the american institute for economic
research dr ruger
was this inevitable from day one
yeah i mean sanctions rarely work to
change the behavior of target states you
know
sure you can punish the people of the
state right they can suffer but you're
not going to actually cause state
leaders to give up what they consider to
be so important to their vital national
interests in the case of russia that's
the situation in ukraine so often what
you get is a kind of feel-good response
right this is feel-good activity when
other types of interventions are just
deemed to be too costly like direct
military intervention so you know again
it was for ordained in many many in many
ways and often times when they are
successful they just take a lot of time
and it isn't necessarily on something so
vital like ukraine well the fact of the
matter is the revenue from russia's
fossil fuel exports
have
exceeded
what the country is spending on the war
in ukraine according to a report
in the new york times so
they're making a huge amount of money in
china
as i said back in march once we knew
they were going to be buying
uh oil from russia that was kind of game
over
i mean this was all kind of ridiculous
like kabuki theater in a way
yeah again this is just yet another case
of the kind of unintended consequences
we see from misguided actions i mean you
know we heard about these yachts right
that we had seized and then we have to
pay for their upkeep that's a kind of
small example but we see this in terms
of oil prices food prices and then you
see the united states saying look we
need to provide subsidies for global
food assistance uh and again it's like
you know a case in which these were very
predictable scholars have been studying
this for decades and finding that
sanctions are oftentimes not very
helpful so again very predictable and
you know really that's kind of typical
of what we've seen from this
administration are our policies that
sound like they're going to be helpful
to the american taxpayer or people
abroad but they actually shoot ourselves
in the foot yeah i thought that whole
seizing the yacht thing was such
again it was it was kind of
choreographed theater it looked kind of
sexy you're going to take the take the
big yachts and that's going to show them
but it did it did nothing and now we're
having to pay as you said for the upkeep
of the oligarchs yachts
william great to see you again as always
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else